oh dis c'est pas vrai merci d'y
sélectionner ou voir bosinger mois ou à
sa chaîne choisit comme à son habitude
ne pouvait s'empêcher d'en faire
ou alors c'est nous c'est comme ça
cherchez pas qu'on cède 1,18 g pas
gâcher ce magnifique moment pour un
appel vidéo banon oui monsieur donnelly
nom me dérangeait pas bon laquelle quand
cette réunion c'est à los angeles
alors là j'avais la vie
tu sens ça sent l'essence mélangé à une
vieille odeur de pizzas inspire
ça sent la liberté texas nous voilà
ça va super sympa merci l'accueil
maintenant qu'est ce que tu fais là ma
chérie tu m'a tellement manqué mon
soutien ma mère avait toujours montré
quelques difficultés à être séparée de
moi et effectivement au bout de 17
heures 55 minutes et 32 secondes
elle avait craqué et c'était dans le
premier iron par dallas
écoute ma chérie tu dis toi bien qu'à
partir de maintenant plus rien ne peut
nous arrêter tu m'entends plus rien